c'est un geste simple qui à l'avenir
pourrait rapporter 15 centimes par
emballage
le gouvernement remet la consigne pour
les bouteilles en plastique au goût du
jour une méthode pour mieux collecter
les déchets dans le centre ville de
pontarlier
la proposition fait débat ça se fait en
allemagne ça marche très bien on va
prendre le faire on le fait pas en
france et bouteilles en plastique si je
les ramène à mon supermarché quand je
vais faire mes courses comme un
saucisson dans mon sac je les vis des
phénix mes courses l'apport volontaire
ici à pontarlier a bien pris depuis le
début je trouve ça un peu dommage ça
fait une activité pour le centre est
également dans ce centre de tri ouvert
en 2015 onze mille tonnes de déchets
sont collectés par an plus de la moitié
provient directement des bacs jours
[Musique]
un trip par matière car le plastique est
un trésor
les usines de recyclage achètent ici une
tonne de ses emballages pour environ 300
euros contre 75 euros pour du carton par
exemple consignait les bouteilles
plastiques seraient une perte d'activité
considérable pour les centres de coûts
pour les dix matières triées au centre
de tri les gros volumes sont les
bouteilles plastiques et les papiers
sont vraiment les deux postes importants
surtout le centre de tri et en termes de
prix en termes de prise ce sont les
bouteilles plastiques on a les plus
grosses recettes matière des centres de
tri privés de leurs produits phares et
des collectivités vent debout contre la
proposition du gouvernement
tous craignent mise en péril du système
actuel de collecte des déchets qui
pénaliserait in fine et le consommateur
le risque c'est con con qu'on transfère
la compétence du recyclage des
plastiques aux grands groupes
industriels
nous on va garder donc points d'apports
volontaires actuels où on aura toujours
possibilité de mettre du vert du carton
du plastique y compris du plastique
salle mais on pourra appeler amener les
bouteilles en plastique parce que sinon
le consommateur perdrait 7,7 consignes
donc fausse bonne idée
une bouteille en plastique sur deux est
recyclé en france l'union européenne
fixe un objectif de 90 % pour 2029
d'ici là l'emballage plastique n'a pas
fini de faire du monde